with a Republican healthcare plan all
but dead in the House of Representatives
president Trump is blaming Democrats for
the plans failure and predicting the
eventual collapse of the Affordable Care
Act or Obamacare this is not anything
but a Democrat healthcare and they have
Obamacare for a little while longer
until it ceases to exist which it will
at some point in the near future so is
Obamacare which will remain the law of
the land really on life support dr. mean
ashesh money is a former director of
health reform at the department of
health and human services during the
Obama administration she is in our
Washington bureau dr good morning thank
you for having me good morning so let's
separate fact from rhetoric here this
the Congressional Budget Office in its
assessment of the Republican plan looked
at the Affordable Care Act and concluded
the non-group market would probably be
stable in most areas under either
current law or the legislation what does
that practically mean that's correct so
if you're going to require that
insurance companies cover anybody who
comes in the door including people who
have health conditions for which they
would want to use health care then you
also have to have healthy people coming
into the market and that would make the
market stable so the Affordable Care Act
does that by two mechanisms number one
with the individual mandate so if people
don't come in if people don't purchase
health insurance coverage what normally
would happen is when they get sick they
go to the emergency room room they end
up using care and then the cost gets
passed on to everybody else but with the
individual mandate if they don't get
health insurance then there is a penalty
and so that encourages people to come in
and purchase coverage and the second way
is through the premium tax credits
because the premium tax credits if
premiums go up then the premium tax
credit goes up as well so that people
especially healthy people don't get
priced out of the market so for instance
about eighty-five percent of people in
the marketplace get a premium tax credit
and for those people from 2016 to 2017
the average increase in premiums that
they experienced out-of-pocket was
and I think another telling fact is that
the percentage of young people in the
marketplace who are in tend to be
healthier people stayed the same from
last year to this year again indicating
stability the ACA has given health
insurance to approximately 20 million
people I think even former president
obama admits though that it's imperfect
do you think it can be fixed well I mean
I'd like to remember that you know we
talked about 20 million people when we
talk about those numbers they're not
just numbers they are real people so I'm
a physician I practiced and took care of
patients before Obamacare and after
Obamacare went into effect I personally
had patients thank me they were able to
get care that otherwise they wouldn't
have been able to get and it helped save
their lives so certainly the Affordable
Care Act has made a huge difference I
think with any large piece of
legislation and any large policy there
are ways that you can improve things
there have been many proposals that have
been put out the president mentioned
quite a few of them last year but we
really also need to focus on improving
value and working and this was developed
in the affordable care act to increase
value in the health care that we provide
all right we thank you dr. meanness ish
money